des supporters berrichon orléans pour
france thaïlande dans un stade bleu
blanc rouge tous fiers de l'équipe de
france féminine de football en général
et de charlotte bilbault en particulier
la milieu de terrain des bleus évoluent
presqu'à domicile comme jeudi la maison
c'est chez moi c'est ma ville à vignoux
sur barangeon ici on va dire que ça à
côté mais c'est parce que c'est pas chez
moi mais on va y avait du monde
d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'on aura un
énorme engouement cet été donc le public
répond toujours présent jusqu'à
maintenant donc ça nous fait du bien et
j'espère que ça va continuer pour la
coupe du monde un public assidu des
éducateurs fier de l'évolution de leur
championne je n'ai entraîné pendant
trois ans à venir de poussins benjamins
et 13 ans elle était plus forte que les
garçons ont plus et je vais vous dire
une anecdote à la fin des entraînements
et des petits matches et à chaque fois
les garçons de les voir ils voulaient
charlotte dans leur équipe elles étaient
mineures avec les garçons elles étaient
au dessus avec les garçons donc oui
c'était on peut pas on peut pas dire
c'est sûr elle fera la carrière qu'elle
a fait aujourd'hui
pour autant on savait qu'il y avait en
tout cas matière à faire quelque chose
de bien derrière et c'est donc ici à
vignoux sur barangeon que tout a
commencé pour charlotte footballeuses
comme son frère et son père toujours
éducateur au club
a priori elle était vraiment fait pour
ça avec une envie c'était prend le
ballon pour s'amuser et très vital à
progresser avec les garçons elles
étaient massées plusieurs sélections
au dessert kiev est très bien au ballon
soit passionné qu'il visait que parler
franchement en 2003 charlotte intègre la
section sportive du collège louis armand
à saint-doulchard c'est la seule fille
de la promotion
à l'époque ses professeurs vote en elle
une élève sérieuse et très à l'écouté
- bon souvenir c'est sûr pour ces
messieurs qui ont chaussé les crampons
avec elle la dga fonds qui était un
serment et puis c'était un petit peu pas
dire moqueur mais un petit peu chambreur
une fille dans cette promo c'est pas
arrivé depuis longtemps
et puis alors je m'adresse à me dire
joueur qui est allé à châteauroux
apprennent et alors j'ai dit dans sa
mire charlotte au bas nous met la misère
à tous oui nous vierzon châteauroux puis
clairefontaine en 2006 la carrière est
lancée le personnage n'a pas changé
charlotte bilbault n'oublie pas d'où
elle vient son club d'origine le lui
rend bien
c'est quelqu'un d'agréable de simple on
puis tout à fait accessible et ça se
fait naturellement qu'india là c'est
comme si à connaissez tous au courant
charlotte bilbault indissociable de
vignoux sur barangeon qui a maintenant
son équipe féminine senior
ils sont plus de 250 licenciés prêt à
l'encourager
[Applaudissements]